tonight live from the Shrine Auditorium
in Los Angeles California the motion
picture capital of the world it's the
61st annual Academy Awards
grunt you buy Revlon the most
unforgettable women in the world where
Revlon kodacolor gold film film that
shows your true colors GE from
satellites to medical systems we bring
good things to life and Diet Coke just
for the taste of it
the move is on to Diet Coke some of the
early arrivals here be 61st annual
Academy Awards Best Actress not an easy
life Jodie Foster here's two times out
of a fight Sigourney Weaver
one man no baby Tom Selleck
fatal attractions and archery and
moonlighting tonight Bruce Willis and
Demi Moore
another nominee tonight Max von Sydow
here's high-flying Tom Cruise
that's Agnes Dominique when closed
Ron Williams
romantic co-stars Kurt Russell in Goldie
Hawn
tap-dancing movie star Gregory Hines
previous winner nominated tonight for
Best Actor Dustin Hoffman
nominate her co-star Geena Davis and
Jeff Goldblum
as actor domine edward james olmos
oscar-winner a nominee gene Hackman
here's comedy star nominee Tom Hanks
and first nominee and best friends Don
Johnson and Nellie Griffith
Supporting Actor nominee Martin Landau
comedy legend Lucille Ball
tonight's last rule Marvin Hamlisch
cuddly Dudley Moore
beautiful and elegant Jacqueline Bisset
tell me star Mardan Shores
tonight's nominee and two-time winner
Meryl Streep
probably accounting from a price
waterhouse who tabulate the balloting
and guarantee the secrecy and the
integrity of the results mr. Frank
Johnson and mr. Dan Lyle